researchers and biologists are teaming
up for a desperate last-ditch effort to
save the rarest of all marine mammals
the vaquita an endangered species of
porpoise is down to the last few dozen
of its type left in the world Don Dahler
went on an expedition in the Gulf of
California to save the species from
extinction as the Sun creeps above the
horizon we head out with a disparate
group of volunteers veterinarians and
marine biologists on a difficult some
would say impossible mission two years
in the making to track the rarest of
marine mammals the vaquita porpoise for
conservation in general of marine
mammals lorenzo rojas Braco is directing
the effort it's been an uphill battle
against the odds the cost now in the
five million dollar range and the
elements might seem calm out here but
when there's any chop in the water at
all the spotters have a hard time
telling the difference between the
little tops of the waves and the dorsal
fins the challenge is amplified by the
fact that there are so few of the
diminutive porpoises left recent reports
show the vaquita population has dropped
from almost 600 in 1997 to just 30 today
found only here in the Gulf of
California the threat is these sunken
nets that are placed out illegally at
night to catch to trauma the vaquita is
rapid decline is an unintended
consequence of the increasing demand for
it to tois these fish can fetch up to
ten thousand dollars each on the Chinese
black market their swim bladder is
believed to boost fertility basically
the mesh size is about the size of a
vaquita head so they easily get
entangled thus the desperate rush to
save some for captive breeding before
they're all gone
fajitas are really small animals they're
about my size
they only are in singles and pairs the
operation requires delicate coordination
spotter boats search the water for fins
when one or more porpoises sighted
trained US Navy dolphins act as herd
dogs moving the porpoises into position
for the capture boats to net them there
then carefully transferred onto a
transport boat first stop a specially
constructed marine hospital for medical
assessment then a short trip to the
vaquita snoo home a large retrofitted
sea pin once used as a tourist aquarium
that was towed here nearly 2,000 miles
from the Pacific the complicated plan
worked at first on day two of the
project they captured one for the first
time ever when you caught the first
juvenile that that first week you must
have felt terrific that you had a chance
to actually succeed oh yeah I mean it
was all Cheers I was just so exciting
that we might actually catch an
individual and maybe
catch enough to save the species but
that six month old female was just too
stressed from the experience they had to
let her go and the team took to the sea
to try again vaquita is in this water
right off of our bow the boats are
moving around right now trying to
encircle him and again and again with
all the species going extinct in this
world every year why is this one worth
saving one every species is worth saving
this is the most endangered Andry mammal
right now so sort of an AA profession
this would be the species that we focus
on but all the effort and expense and
frustration is also to bring the issue
of illegal gill nets to the public's
attention so if we can absolutely ensure
that these underwater gill nets and not
in the place where these remaining
animals are that's they would survive
they could thrive on their own yeah they
just need a chance yeah they just need a
chance for CBS this morning Saturday Don
Dahler Baja Mexico